it's too little too late for Donald
Trump's ban on European visitors panic
has already set in and hordes of
coronavirus Doomsday Preppers are
already raiding supermarket shelves
[Music]
coronavirus has already spread to well
over a hundred countries and territories
worldwide a pandemic according to the UN
it doesn't care about your race creed or
class even millionaires like Tom Hanks
and his wife announced they have fallen
ill and while China's all but got its
own coronavirus situation under control
Washington still putting most of the
blame for everything and anything
connected to the pandemic on China the
Wuhan virus that began at the end of
last year you called it the Wuhan virus
Chinese Communist Party has said that
this is where the virus started China
has unleashed this plague on the entire
world through their dishonesty and their
lack of transparency and corruption it
rather than using best practices this
outbreak and and what was covered up
you'd think they'd understand that being
the origin of a pandemic was out of
Beijing's control but while Washington
continues to throw shade it's forgotten
one crucial point pretty much all US
antibiotics vitamin C pills first aid
supplies are supplied by Chinese
companies America is basically
pharmaceutically dependent on China if
China banned the export of drugs the US
would sink into the hell of a novel
coronavirus epidemic and that's given
Washington more than just the
coronavirus to panic about I think has
been clear for a while now that we are
far too reliant on China for our
domestic production especially for
essential products that we rely on and
of course our medical supply chain is at
the very top of that list
the corona virus outbreak is made clear
we must combat America's supply chain
vulnerabilities and dependence on China
and critical sectors of our economy the
corona virus crisis puts into sharp
focus the unacceptable dependence of the
US on China for critical medicines and
their ingredients by American trend has
gained new traction as a result Trump's
trade adviser is even suggesting a
change in federal law that would force
the feds to buy from American companies
if we have straw
by American procurement that will
establish a robust base level of demand
that provides the appropriate incentives
for our pharmaceutical manufacturers to
invest and locate domestically worried
yet with all of Big Pharma's
profit-making schemes in the past the
outrageous lifelong cost of HIV
treatment in the u.s. spiking the prices
of insulin it doesn't take an economist
to wonder how the already high price of
drugs might skyrocket the disruption of
the supply chain is what drives the
market down we have off you know shored
many of these production of items not
maybe the product itself but maybe a
component of the product that's very
basic and anyway come to United States
to get more you know manufactured so
clearly it's underlines how vulnerable
we are as a first world country you know
on China to produce these basic products
so while you and I see the corona virus
pandemic as a tragedy of world
significance big business will try every
which way to turn it into a
profit-making extravaganza for
themselves of course whenever there's a
crisis somewhere there's always there to
make some money off it come on you know
now you're gonna start seeing people are
gonna be at home so you're gonna see
Netflix go up or other you know online
or you're watching platforms Hulu or
whatever the case might be
and same thing with medications